INSTRUCTOR: Hello, vizzers.
This is a design starter
for the cereal makeover,
and I'm going to jump into the--
here's that article.
I'm going to jump into
the assignment itself.
So take a look at this one.
The cereal challenge
is the question
of healthy or unhealthy.
There's some background
reading when it
comes to some of these cereals.
And the data source is
a source from Kaggle.
It has the 80
different data sources
that are available to it.
Let me go and jump
into the Kaggle here.
And let's go ahead
and see all of that.
You can see all of the different
data sources they've got here.
They even have a
data set summary,
which is kind of nice to take
a look at about this data set.
Sometimes Kaggle provides
some really good sources
from our fellow data
nerds out there.
So for your project, if you
haven't checked out Kaggle,
K-A-G-G-L-E-.com, I
would certainly do that.
The link can also be found
on the resource page.
So I am going to download that
cereal Excel file, bring that
into Tableau.
You'll notice here that I've got
some headers of cereal and name.
This is not needed.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to use the data interpreter.
Just by clicking that, it will
clean up some of these headers
that default in a downloaded
file from Excel or CSV file.
So if you haven't
used that yet, that's
a really good tool to see if it
will clean up some of your data.
So you don't have to
go back into the file
or do other types of
cleaning activities.
OK, so you'll also notice
that the interpreter
went ahead and named these.
So we've got the name.
We've got the manufacturer
type, calories, et cetera.
If I wanted to make that
capitalized, I could do that.
I can just rename it right
there, et cetera, et cetera.
So can see all of the
different fields that we've got
brought in.
I've got just 77 rows.
And I could rename this.
Let's go ahead and
rename this to cereal.
OK just keeping it clean.
Cleaning up my data
set a little bit
before I jump to my first sheet.
OK, so the first
thing that you'll do
is you're going to recreate at
least one of those three charts
since it was a quasi-dashboard.
So this is the OG, the
original that you're
going to be making as
part of your step 1.
And I'm also going to do
a little cleaning up here
on the data pane.
So this name is
actually the cereal.
So I'm going to rename this just
right here and call that cereal.
And oop-- OK, let me see.
It's doing that count.
Let me go back to my
data source so I can see.
I'm going to try to
do that right in here.
We'll just rename that to
be cereal if it already
exists on the logical level.
So I must have
ratings of cereal.
I think it's counting this.
So let's go ahead and
rename this to data.
Now, let's see if
I can rename this.
Awesome.
OK.
And then that's just the type,
whether it's hot or cold.
So looks good.
All right.
So sometimes because our data
is labeled from our various work
groups or businesses,
sometimes it
is great just to take
a little bit of time
to rename the fields so that
you remember what they are,
and they're more clear
and working with the data
to make that visualization.
So before I remake
the OG, I just
want to check out
some of the data here.
So I'm going to just
put manufacturer on rows
so I can see who I've got--
American food.
I'm not quite sure who that is.
I'll find that out.
GM, Kelloggs, Nabisco,
Post, Quaker Oats, Purina.
GM does a lot of hiring
here at the Huntsman School.
So that's kind of fun.
Let me bring that
cereal right next to it.
Oh, Maypo.
So that's why I've
never heard of that.
But now I can see
the cereals that
are in the data set
according to manufacturer,
and then one of
the things I think
is interesting display shelf.
If I put that on the
text then I can see
that there's different numbers.
I think this is placement.
So cereal manufacturers
can place or pay
additional in the grocery store
for placement at eye level.
And I think that number
3 is at eye level.
I think number 1 is up high.
2 is below, and then
3 is that eye level
is what I think that that is.
I may have to go check that.
OK, so what I want to do
is just clear this off.
One trick you can do is just
click this above button.
Instead of dragging all of these
off, you can just click that.
That will restart your
view on that same sheet,
which is the OG.
So the first thing I want
to do is, I'm going to--
actually I've already done this.
So let me delete that
and move that back.
All right, so this
is probably what
you're looking at right now.
And I was looking at
the rating of cereal.
This is telling me if
it's healthy or unhealthy.
So instead of having that
being a continuous measure,
I'm going to bring this up and
make that into a dimension.
And then I'm going to--
looks like it's already
converted to that dimension.
But you probably
have to put down.
Let's convert to
continuous right here.
So let's bring that
on to columns here.
And then let's bring in the
count the cereal data count
that Tableau does as a default.
Now, I've just
got one line here.
So what I want to
do is I'm going
to go to this rating
of cereal, and I'm
going to create some bins.
So I'm going to
create a histogram
to see where those are at.
So right there, I'll do a
Create and I'll do a Bins.
And I'll just call
this RATING BINS.
And Tableau recommends
doing 5, a little over 5.
So I'll just say, OK on that.
And then I'll take that.
And then just drop
that onto the columns
and then remove the other one.
So now what I have is,
I've got this distribution,
and I can clean that up.
So it's not maybe that 0.9.
So maybe I remove that 0.1.
So I've got one here
as that outlier.
And that's the healthiest.
Let's go ahead and put down
the cereal on the label.
Oh yeah.
So now, you can see all
bran with extra fiber.
Is that one.
This is breaking them
all down individually.
So whether you go
that route, or let's
just put it on the tooltip.
So now, we've gone back
to that cleaner version,
and I've got that all bran.
The problem is as soon as I
just have one, if I've got two,
it can't give me
the individual data
unless I want to change and
create a calculation for that.
OK, so that is one of the OGs.
Let me go back and check
out what the other ones.
So I'm looking at this
one, which was the top 10
cereals with the most sugar.
OK, so let's go
to sheet number 2,
and I'm going to
call this that--
we're going to still
call this the OG O2.
Actually I don't think
they have the histogram.
This is probably-- gosh,
let me look right here.
Yeah, they didn't
do a histogram.
So this actually is going
to be my first wild card.
I just did it first, I guess.
So we're going to
call this the OG one.
And we're going to look at
grams of sugar by cereal,
and it's aggregated
to sum automatically.
I can do a descending
sort I don't
think they showed all of these.
They said top 10.
So let's go ahead and bring
in cereal onto filters
and do a top search by field.
Now, I can put in
whatever I want,
but I just need
10 grams of sugar.
Great.
OK, so let's see what that is.
Oh, OK, let's fix
this to be entire view
and smacks and golden crisp
and smacks and golden crisp.
And looks like they've
got two highlighted
with different colors.
And you could choose to do that
for your design if you want to.
Calories and sugar, top 10
cereals with the most calories,
interesting, and
they have another--
let's see if we can
do another OG 2.
Let me just move that over here.
So we'll do grams
of complex fiber.
What was the calories and sugar?
So calories per serving.
And then we're
doing cereal again.
We'll do-- filter that.
We'll do top 10
again by calories,
and then we'll just select that.
Gosh, that's pretty even.
What else do they have here?
Calories and sugar.
So they had another.
So I might be able to put sugar
onto color to see the darker--
gosh, really?
Wow, 13.
That's kind of crazy.
Mueslix and total Raisin Bran.
So the darker the color
has, the more sugar in it.
So that could be
the OG number 2.
What's the other the third
one is calories versus sugar.
So this looks like
a scatter plot.
So let me--
OG 3, just bring that over here.
So we're looking at calories.
Gosh, I forgot my sugar.
So we've got two
measures right here.
And then we'll just
disaggregate those.
See where those are at.
Gosh, what is that?
Let me put down.
Quaker Oat, interesting.
OK.
Yeah, all right.
So they've got some
different symbols on there.
Let me go ahead
and close that out.
So basically, we've recreated
those three different chart
types already.
So you've got that.
I did a histogram
as a wild card.
Your next will be to explore
a wild card on your own,
or follow mine.
And then you're going to
select one of these to design,
and that's really where I want
you to focus your time, energy,
and effort.
And designing a chart using
those design principles
and really lifting that out so
that it doesn't look like that.
But it looks awesome.
So hopefully, you're
on the right path.
I can't wait to see
what you create.
And happy vizzing.